la gran región de parís y sus 12
millones de residentes regresan al
bloqueo es muy difícil
búsqueda de la sonda principal pasando
como antes son cuatro los dueños de
negocios también están frustrados más de
230.000 tiendas y otros servicios se
preparan para cerrar sus puertas una vez
más cualquier idea del mar solmar mes y
en la filmación clip fue el y azules
para garzón
el gobierno insta nuevamente a trabajar
desde casa estos ingenieros sólo vienen
a la oficina una vez a la semana
no a los que su jefe dice que el sistema
es menos eficiente que cumplir el plan
técnico
las nuevas restricciones entran en vigor
el viernes a medianoche